في بغداد نظمت تجمعات شبابيه وناشطون وقفه
احتجاجيه امام البنك المركزي العراقي بسبب
انخفاض سعر صرف الدينار العراقي مقابل
الدولار
بمحيط المنطقه الخضراء اذا لم تتحقق
مطالبهم وكان البنك المركزي العراقي قد
اعلن قبل اسابيع اتخاذ اجراءات جديده قال
انها تهدف الى حمايه استقرار السوق بينما
اعلن رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شيعه
السوداني قبل يومين اعفاء محافظ البنك
المركزي من منصبه
هذا ويعيشوا العراق وازمه ارتفاع سعر
الدولار مقابل الدينار فقد سجل سعر
الدولار في الاسد الماضيه اعلى مستوى له
منذ سنوات طويله بعد بلوغه 1700 دينار
عراقي للدولار الواحد وتعود الازمه الى
كانون الاول ديسمبر من العام 2020 حيث
اعلنت حكومه رئيس الوزراء العراقيه السابق
مصطفى الكاظمي تغيير سعر صرف الدولار من
217 دينارا للدولار الواحد الى
1450 دينارا وذلك بسبب تراجع اسعار المفصل
العالميه
2002 ومعوده ارتفاع اسعار النفط في السوق
العالميه رفضت الحكومه دعوات لاعاده سعر
الدينار الى مكان عليه
اعلان البنك المركزي ان ارتفاع سعر الصرف
الاخير ناجم عن
اجراءات هدفها حمايه القطاع المصرف
وزاره الداخليه اعتقال من وصفاتهم
بالمتلاعبين باسعار صرف الدولار ومن
يعملون على تهريبه وارباك السوق